[Musique]
la tête haute nous sommes la France au
milieu des peuple du monde VI de
[Musique]
de
président voici au milieu de toutes ses
mains tendues comme pour une amicale
distribution de légende l'homme de ce
temps sur lequel on aura probablement le
plus écrit sans parvenir à
l'expliquer incarnation de la résistance
il résiste aussi à
l'examen il est entré dans l'histoire au
moment où la 3è République prenait la
douloureuse décision d'en sortir elle
avait remporté la première guerre
mondiale
elle allait succomber au seuil de la
seconde fidèlement accompagné jusqu'à sa
dernière demeure par Monsieur Albert
Lebrun réduit par la Constitution au
rôle meet d'appariteur des catastrophes
la rencontre fortuite du président de la
République et du colonel de Gaulle aux
abord du front peut-être considéré par
l'historien comme une variante
anecdotique du solstice de juin l'un va
croîre l'autre
diminuer l'oficierf avec une amertume
sans nom la justesse des vues qu'il
s'est vainement employé pendant des
années à faire partager aux grandes
autorités militaires de son
pays le président n'aura bientôt plus
que de nouvelles combinaisons
ministérielles à opposer à la vague de
fer qui va dévaster la France en ne
rencontrant sur son chemin que de rares
obstacles notamment deux fois le même à
LAN à abville le général de brigade à
titre temporaire Charles de Gaulle à la
tête des chars qu'il avait demandé très
tôt et qu'on va lui donné trop
[Musique]
tard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier président du conseil de la 3e
République Monsieur Paul Rena se
souvenant de l'officier dont il avait
été à peu près le seul à soutenir les
théories devant le Parlement appellera
de Gaulle au sous-secrétariat d'État la
défense
nationale mais il y a déjà plus de
[Musique]
nationale
les Allemands défilent à
Paris il ne peut plus y avoir pour la FR
qu'une défense
internationale le 16 juin 1940 monieur
Paul Ren abandonne ses pouvoirs au
Maréchal ptin le 17 résolu à poursuivre
le combat de GA vol vers l'Angleterre à
bord d'un petit avion qui emporte avec
lui plus tard Churchill l'honneur de
laance il aprè 50 ans et de rares
familiers sauront ce que lui a coûté la
décision qu'il vient de
[Musique]
prendre
de Gaul c'est d'abord un phénomène
radioélectrique voyageant sur onde
moyenne pendant des années les Français
ne connaîtront de lui que cette voix
étrangement houleus brouillé par toutes
les créelles de l'occupant les premiers
mots qu'elle allait prononcer devaient
rester indéfiniment dans toutes les
mémoires et c'est heureux le 18 juin
1940 les techniciens de la BBC se dout
si peu qu'ils avaient l'honneur de
diffuser un appel historique qu'il
négligèrent de
[Musique]
l'enregistrer moi général de Gaul
j'entreprends ici en Angleterre cette
tche
nationale j'invite tous les militaires
français desé de terre de mer et de
l'air j'invite les ingénieurs et les
ouvriers français spécialistes de
l'armement qui se trouvent en territoire
britannique ou qui pourrai y
parvenir à se réunir à
moi j'invite les
chefs les soldats les marins les
aviateurs des forces français de mer de
l'air où qu'il se trouvent ement à se
mettre en rapport avec
moi j'invite tous les Français qui
veulent rester libre à m'écouter et à me
suivre vive la France libre dans
l'honneur et dans
l'indépendance mais qui donc était cet
inconnu dont la voix tout à coup
retentissait dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
il est né le 22 novembre
1890 à Lille dans cette demeure de la
rue
princesse
c'est le deuxè fils d'une famille de 5
enfants qure garçons et une fille dont
on relève la trace fort loin dans le
passé les bons auteurs rappelant qu'il y
avait un de GA à la bataille d'azincour
dont il avait naturellement désapprouvé
le dispositif le jeune Charles Liberon
qui lui enseigne le mouvement et pegy
qui lui parle de l'unité française et de
ses inséparables contradiction les un
remarquent son intelligence visible d'AI
loin que sa personne les autres son
caractère pe enclin à la transaction et
au compromis tout le monde s'apercevra
de bonheur que le jeune garçon a la
vocation militaire moins peut-être par
goût des armes que par attrait pour
l'état exceptionnel ou dans les grandes
circonstances l'action ne fait qu'un
avec la pensée il a dans l'esprit
mais peut-être est- dans le cœur une
certaine idée de la France il se
représente sous les trait d'une
princesse de conte à servir avec
exactitude et si possible avec gêné à
saintcir où il entre en 1910 ses
camarades remarquent surtout sa taille
qui offre à la brimade un intéressant
supplément de surface
corrigé mais la guerre de 14 éclate il
sera blessé trois fois sa dernière
citation résume sa manière le capitaine
de Gaulle alors que son bataillon
subissait un effroyable bombardement a
enlevé ses hommes dans un assau furieux
et un corps à corps farouche est tombé
dans la mêlée officier hors de pare à
tous égards éloge est signé Pétin
grièvement blessé le capitaine de Gaul
est fait prisonnier siôt rétabli il
s'évade on le reprend sans difficulté il
n'a pas les moyens de passer inaperçu il
s'évade une deuxième fois avec un
uniforme allemand trop court qui fait de
lui un enfant de troupe géant les
gendarmes le ramènent au camp à la
troème tentative il est interné au
foringolstad puis à
ludwiffen et c'est la fin la princesse a
gagné la guerre et pour combien de temps
l'Allemagne passe par la République de
Vemar et se donne finalement pour ainsi
dire sans le faire exprès au génie le
plus malfaisant de son répertoire
lyrique en France la Marne est redevenue
une rivière à guinguette la princesse
reprend son papotage et son canotage à
l'abri du béton coulé le long de sa
frontière de l'Est par des experts
amnésiques qui arrête la ligne maginau
au point précis où commencent les
invasions le colonel de Gaulle multiplie
les livres les articles les démarches
les conférences les mémorandum la
prochaine guerre sera une guerre de
mouvement où l'arme blindée jouera un
rôle
décisif la Guer a été ce qu'il avait dit
qu'elle
serait ici non la défaite française a
été causé par la force mécanique
aérienne et terrestre de l'ennemi nous
croyons que l'honneur des
Français consiste à continuer la guerre
au côté de leurs alliés et nous sommes
résolus à le
faire nous espérons qu'un
jour une force mécanique
supérieure nous permettra d'avoir la
victoire et de délivrer la patrie
il rassemblera les tronçons d'une armée
éparpillé par la foudre pour constituer
les premiers contingents de la France
Libre chaque jour des volontaires isolés
atteignent l'Angleterre ils viennent
généralement de France sur de petits
bateaux dont ils ont pu
s'emparer et par un beau jour de juin
une flottigue de chalutier amènera à de
Gaulle tous les hommes valides de l'île
de
Saint quelques petites unités navales
trois douzaines
d'aviateurs quelques centaines de
soldats c'est ça la France
libre fin juillet le total des effectifs
atteint à peine 7000
hommes
mais qu'importe en attendant de
contribuer à la défaite de l'ennemi
cette petite armée du refus chassera
l'occupant de l'âme de chaque
Français car cette guerre se déroule
simultanément sur deux plans sur le plan
des opérations militaires l'Angleterre
admirable de sangfroid et de résolution
reste pour un long moment seul à combat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette guerre se déroule aussi sur le
plan de l'idéologie où l'Allemagne du
sang et de la race est auise avec la
morale quand on a pluson n pas encore
les moyens d'être présent dans le
premier DEES de
combats on peut toujours participer
au
cela s'appelle sauver
l'honneur ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde cassé de son grade de Gaul sera
condamné à mort par
[Musique]
Vichy à Londres il est à la fois ce
soldat Charné à empêcher son pays de
signer une capitulation morale plus
grave encore que
[Musique]
l'autre il est aussi ce londonien qui
attend comme tous les autres dans son
cottage que le dimanche
[Musique]
passe
au loin très loin l'appel du 18 juin a
trouvé un écho qui ne cessera amplifier
lentement l'Afrique
répond et d'abord le
Tchad g avec les maigres forces dont il
dispose il rencontre un officier qui va
filer comme une torpille jusqu'au flan
de
l'Allemagne C officier s'appelle
Lecler et il est l'ami de ce gouverneur
Félix qui ne peut pas croire que la
France n'est
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au Proche Orient à beyouth
l'enchevêtrement des intérêts des
influences des combinaisons politiques a
créé une de ces situations inextricable
qui ne peuvent être dénoué que par une
idée simple cette idée la voici toujours
personnifiée par de Gaul elle consiste à
ne pas se tromper d'ennemis de Gaul
confiera le Levant à un général plus
ancien George Catrou asses généreux et
clairvoyant pour se mettre aux ordres de
son
[Musique]
cadet
en
1941 les territoires riés à la France
libre en Afrique et au Proche Orient
réclament une administration centrale
qui ne sera pendant quelqu temps qu'un
comité le Comité National de Libération
logé avec tous les pouvoirs publics dans
quelques pièces d'un immeuble londonien
René plév René maer René Cassin tels
sont entre autres les premiers
administrateurs d'une France à
recommencer sans oublier Maurice Schuman
administrateur de l'espérance parler
l'événement confirme jour après jour le
thème et les prédictions des appels
successifs de juin 40 la guerre devient
d'une guerre mondiale l'Allemagne se bat
sur un frond de plus en plus étendu elle
a attaqué la Russie elle yigèle en
Afrique elle brûle à birakem une poignée
de Gauliste commandée par Kenig résiste
16 jours à om selon Churchill c'est l'un
des plus beaux faits d'armes de cette
guerre et c'est le 7 novembre
1942 les angloaméricains débarquent en
Afrique du nord pour trouver sur place
une situation qu'ils auront contribué de
leur mieux à rendre inextricable et pour
commencer les troupes de Vichi leur
résiste
chef soldat marin aviateur fonctionnaire
colon français d'Afrique du Nord
levez-vous aidez nos alliés joignez-vous
à eux sans réserve la France qui
combat les alliés qui entretiennent des
relations diplomatique avec le maréchal
Pétin et des relations tendues avec de
Gaulle je suis trop pauvre leur
dira-t-il pour ne pas être intrigeant
ont découvert en la personne du général
Giro l'interlocuteur idéal qui ne
représente ni Vichi ni la
résistance l'amiral d'arl dauphin du
maréchal prépare un renversement
d'alliance personnelle brutalement
interrompu par un coup de
pistolet les Alliés imposent GIR sans
qu' parviennent à s'imposer à la demande
de Roosevelt on organise enfin une
poignée de main pour les photographes et
pour l'expédition de difficulté locale
un comité bicéphale que de GA et Giro
présideront à tour de rôle solution
transactionnelle dépourvu
[Musique]
d'avenir
tandis que l'on organise l'armée qui
désormais prendra part dans le bon sens
à toutes les grandes opérations
libératri une assemblée consultative
donne un début de Parlement à la
République nouvelle qui succéder au
régime pénitentiaire de l'État
[Musique]
français un gouvernement provisoiretera
ce dispositif de succession GIR est
commandant en chef
le tandem imaginé par Roosevelt n'aura
pas tardé à se dissocier GIR est un
excellent soldat de Gaulle est un
symbole en activité leur conjonction au
sommet n'était qu'une illusion
d'optique quand à l'ennemi on va le
chercher là où il est dans la neige en
Russie le grand reflux a commencé la
plus puissante armée que le monde a
jamais vu connaît le même sort que celle
de Napoléon les Russes ajoutent quelques
étoiles au croix de Lorine de
l'escadriille Normandie Yemen dont
l'effectif faute de pouvoir se renforcer
se multiplie dans le ciel qui ne gèle
pas en Italie la France Libre participe
à la bataille avec des moyens plus
étendus les chefs s'appellent juin
montsaber bettoire de l'âtre de Tassini
pour la première fois de leur histoire
les Italiens voient arriver des Français
par le sud
dans ce paradis des artistes et des
archéologues les blindés sont priés
d'éviter les faux mouvements on fait la
guerre dans un musée au cartes
d'étatmajur il faut joindre un
Bek
l'axe n'est plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
ça et là quelques éclaircis discipent la
ré du malheur étendu depuis des années
sur
[Musique]
l'Europe et la France et bien il y a une
France souffrante et dans son purgatoire
elle écoute tous les soirs au
rendez-vous de 9h15 des nouvelles de sa
liberté
future entre son peuple réduit au
silence et le général que l'on dit
rebelle une cnivance profonde s'est
établie les Français savent de sources
sûr celle de la foi celle de l'instinct
que par un important détour leur
histoire national passe par de
Gaulle la résistance lentement
s'organise ce ne sera jamais un parti si
ce n'est le parti de la la France
siégeant dans les maquis et dans les
prisons décimé dans le combat du plateau
des Glières et sur les pentes sanglantes
du
vercor le débarquement du 6 juin ramène
de Gaulle dans le pays qu'il attendait
depuis 4
ans
d'abord à cour
seul
la
BA la joie monte comme une irrésistible
marée l'enemi ayant emporté la
collaboration dans ses bagages la France
conna un rare moment d'unité dans le
parfait désordre des grandes heur
[Musique]
national
le 6 juillet de Gaul va rendre visite au
géants
[Musique]
américain
il est accueilli par Roosevelt à la
maison blanche comme un
[Musique]
allié puis comme un champion du monde
libre avant le dernier combat pour le
titre des milours par le maire de New
York
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laardia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
heureux de vous accueillir à New
York vous qui êtes le symbole de la
France au
combat de la France
[Applaudissements]
libre je vousci vi ur ma et
vous pour l'exceptionnelle amitié de
votre
réception bonne chance à vous
tous hommes et femmes qui lut pour la
démocratie pour la liberté pour la
victoire bonne
chanceork VI le peuple
[Applaudissements]
américain
[Musique]
mais c'est à Paris que les victoires se
mettent en parole et en musique
populaire et dès lors il n'est plus que
de laisser la place aux images qui évo
tour à tour les journées
révolutionnaires d' temps le bal public
et la lever en
masse les chars de Lecler et le
soulèvement des Parisiens ont contraint
l'occupant à
[Musique]
capitul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu l'as
vu
[Musique]
paris paris
tragé paris brisé paris
martyrisé mais
Paris
libéré libéré par lui-même libéré par
son peuple avec le concours m armées de
la France avec l'appui et le concours de
la France tout
entiè de l'étoile à NotreDame la légende
se déploie sur la ville
ressuscitée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Go Gol
go
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la guerre le permettra le gouvernement
convira la nation
à par les sourage universel de tous les
hommes et de toutes les femmes de
représentants dont la Réunion formera
l'Assemblée
nationale bien entendu les problèmes
n'ont pas disparu avec l'ennemi
on en voit du genre
ardu une république à refaire la trè
ayant pris congé depuis 4 ans une
population à ravitaillé qui sa
libération partielle encore avec des
produits de
synthèse une subversion intérie à
éviterun des partis de la résistanceant
sur les autres l'avantage de la cohésion
et
l'armement et une guerre à
finir l'Allemagne l'a perdu elle le sait
depuis longtemps mais Hitler n'a pas
encore tout à fait perdu l'Allemagne il
faudra lui arracher des mains lambau par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lambau
le pays se reconstitue non sans secous
ni injustice la France Libre redevient
la France tout court mais elle n'a pas
encore repris les habitudes et les aises
de la liberté
à chaque occasion fournie par
l'événement ou le calendrier la
libération
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
recommence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Churchill recevra sa juste part du
joyeux et intarissable
[Applaudissements]
mar
[Musique]
mais la guerre n'est pas encore
terminée l'Alsace n'est pas encore
délivré les chars de Lecler à la pointe
des armées alliées s'en
[Musique]
chargeront les affiches de l'ordre
nouveau se décolle toute seule et les
innombrables croixgamé qui rongent
Strasbourg replient définitivement leurs
pattes
[Musique]
cassées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en décembre 44 de GA ira signé à Moscou
une alliance des plus traditionnelles on
jouera pour lui et pour son ministre des
Affaires étrangères George Bidau
président du Conseil National de la
Résistance l'hymne languissant et
quelque peu britannique qui a remplacé
l'international
monsieur Molotov n'est pas encore le
monsieur nietet des conférences
internationales Staline se donne avec
talent les apparences trompeuses du
tyran des
bonir
et la guerre n'en finit plus de
[Musique]
finir les Français arriveront les
premiers à biresgaden dans les ruines du
célèbre nidg d'ù sont partis les idées
diffores et meurtillères qui ont jeté le
monde dans la plus sanglante de toutes
les guerres
et cette fois on peut le dire c'est bien
la fin des
fins adolp Hitler a terminé sa carrière
dans l'embrasement prévu les filets
alliés ne ramènent plus que de jeunes
recr d'âge scolaire ou de vieux
combattants qui cumulent la retraite
militaire et la retraite
[Musique]
civile
les journaux assèent une dernière
manchette au 3è Reich les uns célébrant
la victoire alliée les autres la défaite
allemande et quelquesuns la
paix à podam le 9 mai
1945 un peu moin de 5 an après les
prophéties de juin les généraux
allemands signent la capitulation de
leur
[Musique]
pays quoi s'écrira en apercevant de lâre
de TASS la France aussi
oui la France aussi les drapeaux
français sont à leur place parmi ceux
des peuples
libres
et comme de juste Paris va fêter
l'événement pour la 4e et la 5è fois la
Marseillaise de Rude n'a jamais entraîné
autant de monde dans sa vague
tumultueuse victoire victoire la foule
ne se lasse pas d'acclamer et d'user de
sa libre respiration
[Musique]
recouvrée
la guerre est
gagnée voici la
victoire le commandement français était
présent et parti à l'acte de
capitulation l'Allemagne est abattue et
elle a signé son
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désastre
mesdames
messieurs la victoire est aux dimensions
de la
guerre
l'Allemagne avait voulu que la
lutte fut
politiquement ement
moralement une lutte
totale il fallait donc que la
victoire fut une victoire totale cela
est
fait en tant
qu'État en tant que
puissance en tant que doctrine le
raallemand est complètement
détruit une chose est certaine
la
France a engagé dans cette guerre tout
ce qu'elle était
elle a joué non
seulement son existence en tant que
nation mais encore le destin physique et
moral de chacun de ses enfants et elle a
gagné
lae ses droits en attendant avec une
certaine impatience de reprendre ses
habitudes on vote pour rebâtir des
institutions que tout le monde veut
républicaine sans que tout le monde voit
la République de la même façon
l'entreprise constitutionnelle réserve
des
[Applaudissements]
déboirs
on forme des ministères avec des noms
connus moins connu
ou
célèbre
et l' fait de rechef la France perdue et
retrouvée avec eisenher commandant en
chef des forces alli décoré par de GA
sous l'Arc de Triomphe et l'on redescend
une fois encore vers les chevaux de Mar
sous la rafale des
[Applaudissements]
viv et l'on pousse jusqu'à cler
Montferrand où l'enthousiasme est le
même
[Applaudissements]
qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
mais si grand que soit le prestige du
général et le respect qu'inpire les
services a rendu déjà les vieilles
divisions reprennent le dessus à moins
que ce ne soit le dessous et les
spécialistes s'emploient efficacement à
enrayer le pouvoir les partis qui ont
repris leur jeu mystérieux ne manquent
pas encore à la reconnaissance qu'ils
doivent à de Gaul non au contraire il
lui élrait volontiers une statue à
condition qu'il se laisse enfermer
dedans il préfère s'en aller le 20
janvier 1946 après avoir rendu la
liberté aux autres il reprend la sienne
sa décision étonne les Français qui n
connaissent pas les motifs et stupéfient
le milieu politique qui les connaît très
[Musique]
bien il prendra tout de même la parole
un peu plus tard à Bailleux où il donne
en vain les grandes lignes des
institutions qui croit nécessaire à la
[Musique]
France du Parlement ainsi composé de
deux chamb il est clair que ne peut pas
et ne doit pas procéder le pouvoir
exécutif sous peine d'aboutir à cette
confusion des pouvoirs qui aurait pour
résultat que le gouvernement de la
France ne serait bientôt plus
assemblage de
délégation au chef de l'État la fonction
de promulguer les lois et de prendre les
décrets parce que c'est vis-àvis de
l'État tout entier que ceci comme cl
engage les
citoyens nous avons
accomplir une rénovation profonde malgré
d'immes difficultés
nous avons assuré le destin de la France
malgré tous les obstacles qui se dress
sur mais sa VO ne parvient plus à
dominer le REM ménage des CB des
combinaisons de GA retourne à Colomb où
il entreprend la rédaction de ses
[Musique]
mémoires
l'homme du 18 juin revais sa solitude
comme un vieux manteau
[Musique]
familier
pendant 12 ans il goûtera comme le héros
de Paul Claudel la seule récompense
qu'il mérite et qui soit digne de lui
l'ingratitude
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps à Paris la 4e
République expérimente un système conçu
pour sa propre
[Musique]
ruine mais l'histoire de Charles de
Gaulle n'est pas fini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 13 mai
1958 un deuxè péril national le rent au
français
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre avant d'évoquer
cette deuxème période gaulienne parlons
rapidement de cette traversée du désert
qui a duré un peu plus de 12 ans général
de gaaule comme on vient de vous le dire
était retourné à la Boisserie à Colombé
les deux églises il était seul il
écrivait ses mémoires seul quelques amis
lui restaient fidèles car ils étaient
convaincus que la France un jour aurait
encore besoin de lui l'ont même
convaincu une fois persuadé
de tenter une expérience sur le plan
politique ils ont créé le RPF c'était
l'échec de Gaulle est retourné plus
solitaire que jamais à colomberé les
deux
églises en France la guerre du Vietnam
était terminée mais les complications
surgissaient en
Algérie la crise algérienne devenait un
véritable cancer qui rongeait la
France les ministères se succédaient les
uns derrière les autres à un rythme
inquiétant et tous les chefs de
gouvernement tombaient sur le même
problème le problème algérien il e alors
des mouvements de foule en Algérie à
Paris subitement on s'est souvenu d'une
adresse qu'on avait un peu oublié celle
de la Boisserie à Colomb les deux
églises et de Gaulle reçu de nombreuses
visites ses amis bien sûr mais aussi des
hommes politique qui n'avaient pas
toujours été ses amis tous il le
suppliit de revenir
d'accord répondit de Gaulle à condition
que ce soit dans la légalité
républicaine et un jour il est monté
dans sa vieille
citroëne s'est dirigé vers Paris pour
s'en expliquer devant les journalistes
c'était la conférence de presse du
palais d'Orsay qui marquait le retour de
De Gaulle aux affaires comme il disait
lui-même est-ce que j'ai attenté au au
liberté publique fondamental je les ai
rétablis et y AJE une seconde attenté
jamais pourquoi voulez-vous qu'à 67 ans
je commence une carrière de
dictateurors la
République il fut un temps où elle était
René
trah par les partis eux-mêmes et moi
j'ai redressé ses armes ses lois son
nom j'ai fait la
guerre pour obtenir la victoire de la
France mais je me suis arrangé de telle
sorte que ce soit aussi la victoire de
la
[Musique]
République
monsieur le Président de la
République le premier des
Français
est désormais le premier en
France je suis
fier de lui
remettre la charge de cette maison
capitale et d'avoir
ainsi
l'occasion de lui renouveler
l'homage qu'en y
entrant j'avais tenu à lui rendre
au nom de la patrie à jamais
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissance en Algérie la guerre en 4
ans a eu tout le temps de s'installer et
tous les jours des jeunes gens sur cette
terre que l'on ne se résigne pas à dire
étrangère dans les montagnes et dans la
plaine dans les maquis et dans les
villes quadrillage et ratissage sont les
deux servitudes quotidiennes d'une armée
qui ne peut quitter le terrain conquis
sous peine d'avoir à le
reconquérir à cette armée la faiblesse
et l'indécision de la 4e République ont
abandonné peu à peu avec les pouvoirs
militaires les pouvoir civil on ne
distingue plus le soldat et
l'Administrateur les pouvoirs séparés
par la loi sont confondus par les
nécessités contradictoire de
l'assistance de la répression le
militaire et juge préfet quelquefois
maître
d'école
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inversement le simple citoyen reprend du
service sans qu'on le lui demande et
dresse des barricades fragile rempart
qu'il croit élever contre le pouvoir et
qu'il oppose en fait énorme vague
d'indépendance qui d'un bout du monde à
l'autre bout soulève les peuples
autrefois
[Applaudissements]
colonisés cependant l'armée du moins
dans certains de ces cadres menace de
devenir une armée politique un an après
ces barricades c'est le PCH la tentative
de coup
d'état l'armée vous parle vous avez
devant vous les généraux chal jou et
Zeller le 13 mai l'armée française avait
fait le serment solennel mais cette fois
il y a un
état un pouvoir
insurrectionnel s'est établi en Algérie
par un prononciamento militaire ce
pouvoir à une
apparence un Carteron de généraux en
retraite a une
réalité un groupe d'officiers partisans
ambitieux et
fanatique ce groupe et ce Carteron
possède un
savoir-faire limité et
expéditif mais il ne voit et ne
connaissent la nation et le monde que
déformé
au travers de leur
frénésie leur entreprise ne peut
conduire qu'à un désastre
national au nom de la France
j'ordonne que tous les moyens je dis
tous les moyens soit employé
partout pour barrer la route à ces
hommesl en attendant de les
réduire j'ai interdit à tout fr
et d'abord à tous soldat d'exécuter
aucun de leurs
ordres le prononciamento dissipé en
quelques heures la négociation commence
à travers cheminement secret reprise et
faux
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la révolte continue sous le drapeau
noir d'une armée secrète qui s'emploie à
maintenir en état de mobilisation
permanente une population européenne
placée devant une terrible échéance et
qui sans sa terre natale se dérobé sous
ses
[Applaudissements]
pas
la France ne peut pas ne pas prendre
acte de l'irrésistible mouvement des
peuples autrefois colonisé elle ne peut
pas combattre indéfiniment ses propres
principes dans les pays mêmes où elle
les a enseignés elle ne peut pas parler
de liberté et la refusé à ceux qui la
lui demande au nom de son histoire et de
l'image d'elle-même qu'elle a répandu à
travers le
monde
le scrutin d'autodétermination où l'on
verra ces aimables isoloirs enulant
faire une entrée timide encore dans les
bureaux de vote sera confirmé par 90 %
des
Français d'ailleurs en France les
institutions nouvelles qui mettent fin
au régime privilégié des partis fondent
l'autorité du P sur la volonté populaire
directement consulté par voie de
référendum quelques années de stabilité
ont permis d'enlever à la monnaie
nationale de0 superflu ce franc
simplifié encore qu'il complique
quelquefois les additions de la ménagère
qui compte qu'elle reçoit en franc
nouveau et ce qu'elle dépense en franc
ancien a en tout cas rendu à la France
dégager de la majeure partie de ses
dettes une certaine liberté de mouvement
elle en avait besoin pour faire ce qui
restait à faire chez elle et au dehors a
commencé par la décolonisation la
décolonisation un art difficile voyez
plutôt cette scène que l'on ne dira pas
familiale se passe au Congo qui fut
belge elle aurait pu passer d'ailleurs
par exemple dans l'un de ces 13 pays
d'Afrique nous avons su éviter 13
guerres coloniales supplémentaires
accompagné de 13 occasions de guerre
civile bénéfice obtenu en mettant en
pratique à la surprise de beaucoup et à
l'indignation de quelquesuns la devise
inscrite au fronton de nos monuments
publics
bénéfice obtenu en cessant d'imposer nos
ancêtres à des gens qui avaient les leur
en aidant ces hommes à être même et non
plus les ombres de notre présence en
allant en amis plutôt qu'en tuteur chez
ces malgaches tout plein de bienvenue
enoleil c'est au moment où la France les
reconnaissait que ces peuples ont
reconnu la France celle qui parlait
enfin le langage
[Musique]
et tandis que nous mettons fin à nos
guerres le monde partagé à Yalta
continue la sienne connu sous le nom de
guerre froide la France n'est pas là les
grands vont perdre la paix avant même ir
tout à fait gagner la guerre la division
des peuples qui habite l'Europe et
l'Amérique du Nord est la donnée
principale et le pire mal de notre
époque deux camp se dresse face à face
dans des conditions telles qu'il ne
dépend que de Moscou ou de Washington
qu'une grande partie de
l'humanité soit écrasé en quelques
heures ainsi on s'est réuni à Paris pour
mieux se
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
séparer
après avoir partagé le monde en deux
blocs à l'image de la bombe atomique les
experts en situation catastrophique ont
complété le dispositif en installant à
Berlin coupé en 4 et chargé de soldat en
état d'alerte continue une sorte de
détonnateur relié à l'Allemagne
occidentale par le fil dénudé d'une
ligne de communication périodiquement
courtcircuité par les Russes onétne
encore
réis n
pas dans les assemblées internationales
joue le rôle bruyant de l'opposant
systématique la France peut-elle
regarder les deux blocs atteindre leur
masse critique sans se donner les moyens
d'une certaine autonomie
[Musique]
politique n avons pris la
route et nous suivons notre plan
l'effort de
recherche
d'invention de
réalisation que comporte par lui-même
l'armement
atomique introduit dans notre vie
scientifique technique et industriel un
ferment très
efficace nous voici
arrivés au stade des des résultats ainsi
s'ouvre devant
nous la perspective d'une carrière de
dissuasion parce
que attaquer la
France pour qui que ce
soit cela reviendrait à
subir des destructions
épouvantable naturellement le total des
Mégatones que nous pourrons lancer
n'équivaudra pas au total de
celle que l'Amérique et la Russie
soviétique sont en mesure de
déchaîner mais à partir d'une certaine
capacité de destruction atomique et pour
ce qui concerne la défense directe d'un
pays la proportion des moyens n'a pas de
valeur
absolue
[Musique]
le génie des puissances incarcéré dans
la matière ne s'est encore manifesté que
sous la forme bien connue de cette nuée
d'orage dont la fureur vitrifie des
cratères de plusieurs kilomètres de tour
et qui tient depuis 20 ans la planète en
[Musique]
resp
instruite par l'expérience de de guerres
qui lu on coûé autrefois une jeunesse et
guerre 4 ans de liberté la France donne
une force de dissuasion que l'on dira
inutile ce qui tout le monde l'espère
restera éternellement à démontrer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
okre
pourz rester encore une de
minutes de toute façon ce n'est pas sa
force de dissuasion c'est sa force de
persuasion retrouvé que la France va
[Musique]
déployer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en Angleterre où jadis une voix que
personne n'avait entendu a parler un
jour au nom de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France aux États-Unis qui savent à de
Gaul de leur avoir rendu une allié
valide et qui ne sont peut-être pas
fâché de n'avoir aversé pour une fois
que du papier blanc sur un visiteur
européen
en Allemagne
[Musique]
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
es gros
Freude
[Musique]
grossereempfang
dechland
unmittbar in
ber
in
hab
unidkerumfessamsam
[Applaudissements]
fbring et l'on voit les deux voisins
s'asseoir à la même table pour signer
ailleurs que dans un wagon autre chose
qu'un armistice trois guerres ont pris
fin ce
jour-là non la caméra ne vient pas de
faire inopinément un saut en arrière
dans une caserne de la
vermart c'est le globe terrestre qui a
brusquement fait un demi-tour à
gauche du côté de Cuba don krutchov
voudrait faire une sorte de porte-avion
socialiste ancré à quelques encablures
de la Floride mais le joueur d'échec
soviétique s'aperçoit qu'il a poussé son
pion un peu trop loin et il le ramènera
dans ses lignes après quelques jours de
désagréable hésitation la terre retrouve
son équilibre et la presse américaine
qui compte ses salue en de Gaul un allié
difficile mais
sûr dans les palais du Proche-Orient
fermés quelques temps au français et
rouvert depuis peu avec apara lustre et
sainttim sa situation
d'éternel Carrefour
mondial la position aussi qu'il occupe
dans cette région si importante du monde
Moyen-Orient où vivent des peuples avec
lesquels depuis très longtemps la France
entretient des liens et des sympathies
traditionnelles qu'ell souhaite
multiplier tout cela fait en sorte que
l'Iran nous apparaît comme une des
conditions de l'équilibre
universel et de la paix générale mais
deux coups de feu éclate à
Dallas dans l'intervalle de stupeur qui
suit les imprévisibles sentences de
l'absurde on entendra plus que le pas
ralenti des hommes le grincement de la
roue sur la pierre l'envol d'un sanglot
dans une cathédrale de silence on verra
ce qu'on avait jamais encore vu des
Noirs pleurit un blanc nommé John
Kennedy priait pour son repos chantit
doucement pour lui dans leurs églises
mais l'histoire qui ne retient jamais
longtemps son souffle après s'être
arrêté quelques secondes tout de même
sur ses visages d'enfants qui regardent
fuir une espérance passe de l'autre côté
de la terre où elle est attendue depuis
15 ans par une évidence particulièrement
populeuse la Chine que l'Occident semble
avoir autant de mal à reconnaître qu'à
ignorer
et Paris sont convenus
d'échanger les ambassadeurs en nouant
avec ce pays avec cet état des relations
officielles comme M autres nations
libres l'ont fait
auparavant et comme nous l'avons fait
avec d'autres pays qui subissent des
régimes
analogues la France ne fait que
reconnaître le monde tel qu'il
est malheureusement la guerre qui prend
ses ordres ailleurs et ses morts sur
place n'en finit plus de tourner son
vieux scénario éculé dans les extérieurs
piétinés du
Vietnam mais la France qui sait de quoi
elle parle ose une
solutiontique sur le sol asiatique le
général de Gaulle condamne l'escalade
entreprise par Washington au
Vietnam que les
combats qui Rav
l'Indochine nappent par eumême non
plus aucune
issue
suivantelle s'il est un vraiemblable que
l'appareil guerrier
américain puisse jamais être anéanti sur
place d'autre part il n'y a aucune
chance pour que les peuples de
l'Asie se soumettent à la loi d'un
étranger venu de l'autre rive du
Pacifique quel que puissent être ses
intentions et que soit la puissance de
ses
armes bref si long et d que doiv être
encore
l'épreuve il est certain aux yeux de la
France qu'elle n'aura pas de solution
militaire en attendant que l'on veuille
bien prendre le bon sens en
considération la France poursuit
l'agréable pèlerinage des amitiés
retrouvés ici à
Mexico
[Applaudissements]
ces foules accouru illustrent à leur
manière enthousiaste ce que l'on appelle
dans certains comités la politique
d'isolement du
[Applaudissements]
généralénér
gracias senor
presid
meicanos
tro
mico
saludo
Francia
Fran
saludaico
Francia saluda méico con
amistad mi pa
no
libreest libreno
exunina
Alario
noancar
nada es más
importante que la
cooperación de PA como los
[Musique]
nuestros
ide
ho miso
[Musique]
caminoana
misoenir
pu el pueblo
Fran prop al
pueoican
la il viv
[Musique]
meico ce voyage au Mexique sera suivi
quelqu temps plus tard d'un immense
périple en Amérique du Sud voici
l'arrivée à
[Musique]
Caracas
pour bien apprécier avec la chaleur de
l'accueil la valeur du contraste il faut
se rappeler qu'hier les délégations de
l'Amérique latine à l'ONU se voyait
obligé de voter contre nous une ou deux
fois par mois souvenir à classer la
politique française est en redevenu
conforme à sa tradition la France
redevient un peu partout le prénom usu
de la
liberté et l'on offre à son représentant
banderol acclamation fanfare
[Musique]
villageoise ici marseillaise au
piivia Francia Mira ho hacia
Progreso
sois un
pueblo
orgoso
Valiente el pueblo
Fran tieneena
confianza en vestro destino Viva
Bolivia
[Applaudissements]
et marseillaise académique à
[Musique]
Lima
om ma
personne la France et l'armée française
vien rentre au Pérou et à l'armée férus
où curieusement la marche de la Dee dB
donne son élan à ce pas de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parade
flocon tourbillonnant des bienvenu
brésiliennes la croisière s'achève sous
cette averse de petits papiers qui font
à Paris de grands articles d'ancien
fournisseur de catastrophe autrefois
agréé par l'État se demande à quoi bon
ces démonstration à quoi bon ce voyage
mais à quoi donc sert
[Applaudissements]
l'amitié
ce qu' adviendra de votre pays et ce qu'
adviendra de
vous-même intéresse au premier chef le
peuple français pourquoi d'abord en
raison de l'amitié plus que
séculaire qui nous lit par-dessus
l'océan et puis
aussi parce que la France
considère que le destin de l'Amérique
latine et spécialement celui du
Brésil sont des éléments décisifs dans
le Progrès général et l'équilibre
mondial et par conséquent dans la
paix par conséquent dans la paix tout ce
qui sera fait pour rendre plus étroite
et plus
efficace la solidarité naturelle qui
existe entre nos deux pays servira donc
la cause de
l'humanité en 1967 au milieu d'une foule
en délire c'est l'inoubliable voyage au
Canada le Québec qui fait partie de la
grande famille francophone signe avec la
France de multiples accords de
coopération la minorité française du
Canada doit-elle aussi voir ses droits
reconnus et
[Musique]
admis porte de cette réunion inou de
Montréal un souvenir
inoubliable la France
entière c'est voi
entends ce qui se passe
ici et je puis vous dire qu'elle en
vudra mieux vive
Montréal vive le
[Applaudissements]
Québec vive le Québec
libre
l'Europe des 6 pendant ce temps célèbre
son 10e anniversaire en 1958 la
politique européenne existait surtout
dans les textes de Gaul va en faire une
réalité il prend les mesures nécessaires
pour assurer l'intégration de l'économie
française dans la Communauté européenne
le calendrier du traité de Rome est
respecté les discussions ont été longues
et difficiles mais l'Europe des 6
sur le plan économique du moins il reste
à faire l'Europe politique au sein de
laquelle les nations doivent selon le
général de Gaulle coopérer tout en
conservant leur
indépendance quant à l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché commun à
deux reprise le chef de l'État la
rejette non sans s'en être longuement
[Musique]
expliqué de
sair
Grande-Bretagne
actuellement peut se
placer avec le continent et comme lui à
l'intérieur d'un tarif qui soit
véritablement
commun de
renoncer à toute préférence à l'égard du
[Musique]
commonoaise de cesser de prétendre que
son
soit
privilégié et encore de tenir pour caduc
les engagements qu'elle a pris avec les
pays qui ont fait partie qui faisent
partie ou qui font partie de sa zone de
libre
échange cette question là c'est toute la
question on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
soit actuellement
résolue est-ce qu'elle le sera un
jour seul évidemment l'Angleterre peut
répondre la multiplication des rapports
avec l'Europe de l'Est se traduit par de
nombreux accord et contribue à la
détente internationale l'occasion par
excellence non seulement de
RER leur rapport dans les domaines
économiques culturels et scientifiqu
dont dépend leur propre développement
mais
encore d'échanger leur vue
et je l'espère de concerter leurs
actions en vue d'aider à l'Union et à la
sécurité de notre
continent ainsi qu'à
l'équilibre au progrès et à la paix du
monde tout
entier au Proche Orient où la GU est une
men perman le général de Gaul lance des
appels à la
modération il condamne l'attitude
d'Israël en juin 1967 lors de la guerre
des 6 jours et après les représailles
israéliennes contre l'aéroport de
Beyrouth il met l'embargo sur les
fournitures d'armes ce qui ne manque pas
de provoquer de nombreuses réactions à
travers le
monde à l'affrontement dit le général de
Gaulle doit se substituer la
concertation
[Musique]
à l'initiative de la France les
représentants des quatre grands vont se
rencontrer à New York pour essayer de
trouver une solution au problème du
Proche Orient et préserver la
[Musique]
paix conséquence logique de la position
française au sein de l'Alliance
atlantique et des nouveaux rapports avec
a lesays de l'Est la modification des
relations
franco-américaines celles-ci passeront
par diverses phases marqué notamment par
l'attitude française envers la
prédominance du dollar et l'hégémonie
américaine au sein du monde occidental
mais en 1968 les liens se resserent à
nouveau ce rapprochement est confirmé un
peu plus tard lors de l'arrivée de
Richard Nixon à la Maison Blanche et le
président américain déclare de Gaul
croit que l'Europe doit être
indépendante franchement je le crois
[Musique]
aussi
dernière manifestation officielle et
internationale du président de la
République française dimanche 30 mars
1969 le voyage à Washington pour un
ultime adieu à un vieux compagnon
d'armes de tous les héros de la deè
Guerre mondiale un seul vit encore
aujourd'hui symbole d'un passé
[Musique]
inoubliable
et bien après vous avoir rappelé tous
les grands voyages du général de Gaulle
après avoir évoqué les problèmes de
politique étrangère nous revenons en
France pour les dernières années de
présidence du général de Gaulle nous
revenons même un peu en
arrière la chronologie ne sera peut-être
pas strictement respectée mais après
tout qu'importe la chronologie ce soir
elle n'a pas besoin d'être rigoureuse
nous n'avons pas la prétention de faire
uvre
d'historien 1965 c'est l'élection
présidentielle le Comité
central du Parti communiste français a
décidé
unanimement de
soutenir la candidature de François
mitran en tant que candidat
d'union de tous les partis de gauche et
organisation démocratique sans
exclusive devenu le 9 septembre candidat
unique de la gauche François mitteran
affronte Jean Lecanuet le
centriste Jean-Louis titicég encour
l'avocat pierre marcilassi le
sénateur et la candidature isolée de
Marcel Barbu de Gaulle lui n'annonce que
le 4 novembre qu'il sera
candidat au premier tour le 5 décembre
participation record 15 % d'abstention
seulement 10,5 million de voix pour le
général de Gaulle 7,6 million pour
François
[Musique]
mitteran au second tour le résultat est
net le général de Gaulle l'emporte avec
55 % des suffrages contre 45 % à
François mitéran le second sepéna
commence en mars 1967 élection
législative les communistes gagnent 32
sièges et la Fédération 25 un et
Républicains indépendants dépassent
d'une seule voix la majorité absolue
plusieurs ministres ont été
[Musique]
battus monsieur George Pompidou étant
Premier ministre le gouvernement est
remagné par l'installation de Louis Jox
à la justice Alain perfit à l'éducation
nationale et Christian Foucher à
l'intérieur 1968 sera une année
cruciale c'est la première fois que nous
voyons cela c'est-à-dire que de fait ici
nous occupons la
sbonne en mai la révolte d'une minorité
d'étudiants contestataires se propage
comme une traînée de poudre entraîne les
ouvriers à cesser le travail et paralyse
le
pays nul n'a oublié comment la fermeture
de Nanterre celle de la Sorbonne les
heur et les bagarres ont débouché sur
les barricades du quartier latin puis
sur le déchaînement des
[Musique]
violences
c'est la grande manifestation de la
gauche le 13 mai la grève bientôt
généralisée les drapeaux rouges et noirs
l'occupation des bâtiments
universitaires de nombreux lieux de
travail dans la paralysie des organes de
l'État et de la vie du pays le spectre
de la guerre civile apparaît le chef de
l'État redresse le 30 mai en s'adressant
4 minutes à la Nation par radio une
situation qui paraissait
[Musique]
dans les circonstances présentes je ne
me retirerai pas j'ai un mandat du
peuple je le
rempiré je ne changerai pas le premier
ministre je dissous aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée
[Musique]
nationale mil de personnes défilèrent
sur les ChampsÉlysées après laallocution
présidentielle mais était
[Musique]
terminé les élections législatives
firent entrer d'un seul coup au Palais
Bourbon plus de députés élus s la même
étiquette qu'aucune chambre n'en avait
jamais comporté 358
Gauliste
Maurice cou de Murville remplace George
Pompidou à l'hôtel matigon
[Musique]
Edgar for voté par un parlement unanime
le 13 novembre la loi d'orientation
universitaire qui bouleverse les
structures de l'université
traditionnelle en accordant aux
étudiants la participation à la gestion
et au
décisions
au Sénat gaston monerville est remplacé
par Alain
[Musique]
po pendant ce temps c'est à la
participation que se consacre le général
de Gaulle il prépare un référendum sur
la
[Musique]
régionalisation
l'avèement de la
région comme cadre
nouveau de
l'initiative du conseil et de
l'action pour tout ce qui touche
localement à la vie pratique du
pays voilà donc la grande
réforme que nous devons apporter à la
France pour que cette rénovation se
réalise au plan de la
nation comme au plan de la
région nous devons transformer le
Sénat afin qu'il associe dans la
préparation des
lois les mêmes sortes d'élus et les
mêmes sortes de
délégués avec leurs compétences et leurs
responsabilités comme cette profonde
réforme concerne l'organisation de nos
pouvoirs publics dans tous les domaines
y compris celui de la
Constitution nous devons soumettre le
projet au
peuple convaincu de l'importance de ces
réformes pour le développement de la
France le général de Gaulle met encore
une fois son mandat en jeu dans la
bataille de ce nouveau
référendum votre
réponse va engager le destin de la
France parce
que si je suis
désavoué par une majorité d'entre
vous
solennellement sur ce sujet
capital et quel que puisse être le
nombre
l'ardeur de
l'armée de ceux qui me
soutiennent et qui de toute façon
détiennent l'avenir de la
patrie ma tâche actuelle de chef de
l'État deviendra
évidemment impossible et je cesserai
aussitôt exercer mes
fonctions la suite vous la connaissez le
lendemain du scrutin la France se
réveille surprise de son propre verdict
et à l'étranger on ne comprend pas très
bien ce qui s'est passé on ne comprend
pas comment un chef de l'État a mis son
mandat en jeu alors que personne ne lui
demandait sur un référendum qui risquait
de lui être fatal on parle même de
manœuvre politique le général de Gaulle
repart pour Colombet
il proclame à plusieurs reprises sa
volonté de quitter définitivement les
affaires et ses adversaires admettent
rapidement qu'il ne s'agit pas du tout
d'une manœuvre politique que c'est une
véritable volonté le général de Gaulle
retourne à son métier d'écrivain il ne
viendra même pas à Paris de peur d'être
accusé de simissé dans les affaires
politiques françaises il restera à la
Boisserie à Colombet il se permettra
simplement deux voyages à l'étranger un
en Irlande l'autre en
Espagne à la Boisserie le général
retrouve la solitude seul compagne
a-t-il dit dont puisse se satisfaire un
homme qui a rencontré l'histoire il ne
reçoit que de très rares familiers il
écrit les premières pages des mémoires
d'espoir et à la mi mai alors que les
Français vivent la fièvre des élections
présidentielles de Gaulle part pour
l'Irlande accompagné de sa femme et d'un
de camp le voyage a été préparé dans le
plus grand secret il ne comportera
qu'une seule étape officielle une visite
au président De
Valera pour désigner le nouveau chef de
l'État français de Gaulle votera par
correspondance et le 18 juin 1969 pour
la première fois depuis la Libération
le chef de la France libre ne sera pas
au montvérien au milieu de ses
compagnons jamais non plus il n'occupera
le bureau qu'on lui a préparé à Paris
avenue de brotuil il fera un autre
voyage en Espagne au mois de juin il
volera de Parador en Parador de
Saint-Jacques de Compostelle à Grenade à
Madrid il rencontrera Franco il traverse
la Grande Terre catholique au milieu des
voitures de touristes il foule de son
grand pas assuré
les jardins de l'Alambra parmi des
estivants qui le reconnaissent jamais il
ne rompra le silence qu'il s'est
imposé la Boisserie disait-il c'est chez
moi c'est ma maison j'y embrasse les
fonds sauvages où la forêt enveloppe le
site comme la mer bat le promontoire
de Gaulle maintenant se plaît à conter
l'histoire qui l' façonné il fait éditer
ses discours et messages puis le mois
dernier le premier tome des mémoires
d'espoir le renouveau 250000 exemplaires
sont enlevés en quelques
jours t Gaul sortait rarement de la
Boisserie la me le dimanche et la visite
au cimetière où reposait Anne De Gaulle
sa fille auprès de qui il a voulu que
son corps soit étendu à
jamais certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être tendance à l'oublier mais
demain c'est le 11 novembre c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi pour terminer
cette évocation de diffuser un document
qui aujourd'hui prend toute sa dimension
c'est un document inédit vous ne l'avez
jamais vu il a été enregistré à
l'occasion d'un autre 11 novembre en
1962 au Albert Hall de
[Applaudissements]
Londres messieurs mesdames je dis que la
Résistance française négativement et
positivement a fait échouer le plan
politique de Hitler
je dis que sans la Résistance française
les démocraties ne pourraient pas gagner
la guerre mais il reste à faire en sorte
que cette guerre soit gagnée par elle
avec la France je dis la France
c'està-dire c'està-dire une seule nation
un seul territoire un seul empire et une
seule
loi certes dans l'habîe effrayant o nous
aveit fait rouler le désastre et la
trahison 1000 forces centrifuges se sont
exercé sur l'unité de la France alors
certes l'Union nationale subissait de
bien graves dangers et cependant c'est
un fait qu'elle survit et qu'elle
subsiste parmi les Français qu'il soient
dispersés par la force ou qu'il soi
sollicité par le espoir c'est un fait
que l'accord secret des âmes s'est
réalisé et c'est un fait que cet accord
est maintenant publ la masse française
est unie en réalité sur trois impératifs
que voici premièrement l'ennemi est
l'ennemi deuxièmement le salut de la
patrie n'est que dans la victoire
troisièmement c'est dans la France
combattante que toute la France doit se
rassembler
le ciment de l'unité française c'est le
sang des Français qui n'ont pas eux
accepter
l'armistice qui malgré retonde continue
à mourir pour la France de ceux qui
n'ont pas voulu connaître suivant le
verre de Corneille la honte de mourir
sans avoir combattu oui c'est le cas
sacrifice total de certains pour le
salut de tous qui rassemble toute la
patrie soldats morts de kéren Koufra
mourzou Damas birakem hameimat marin de
nos navires coulés narval surcou Alice
mimosa poum Viking chasseur aviateur
tués dans les ciels des batailles
d'Angleterre d'Orient
d'Afrique volontaire française écrasé à
votre poste équipage de nos navires
marchand détruits en service
commandé combattant de saintnazer Tomb
le couteau à la main fusiller de N de
Paris de Lille de Bordeaux de Strasbourg
et d'ailleurs c'est vous qui faites que
la patrie est
indivisible la France est
rassemblée dans une seule volonté et
dans une seule
espérance la France tout entière à la
seule exception des traes et bien de
même
qu'ici nous nous trouvons réunis des
milliers de Français des milliers de
françaises de tous les pays de chez nous
et dont la Réunion donne comme une image
de la patrie elle-même de même dis-je
que nous nous trouvons réunis côte à
côte dans un même acte de foi sous le
signe immortel de notre croix de Lorine
ainsi soyons- en sûr la France sera
rassemblée tout entière dans le dernier
effort
qu'ilattend un seul combat pour une
seule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patrie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est par ce discours enregistré je
vous le rappelle au Alber de Londres le
11 novembre 1942 et non pas 62 comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure par erreur que
nous terminerons cette révocation cette
évocation consacré à la vie d'un homme
qui a connu une destinée d'une grandeur
exceptionnelle